Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
Surf más sobre esto En un momento
[Música]
si creéis que la invasión rusa Ucrania
va a ser la única de la década puede que
estéis en lo cierto pero para hacer tal
pronóstico con garantías eso nos exigía
saber cómo demonios se va a comportar
China ya sabéis que este país lleva un
tiempo amenazando con invadirte One y Sí
seguramente muchos pensaréis que tarde o
temprano La Isla se convertirá en una
especie de nuevo Ucrania Pero y si os
dijéramos que hay quien piensa que
llegado el caso la Ucrania de Asia
podría llegar a ser Vietnam y no da
igual y ojo que no hablamos de meras
especulaciones hay argumentos
suficientes como para pensar que el
riesgo existe aumenta la tensión entre
China Vietnam y filipinas por Islas en
disputa de hecho china ha llegado a
hundir barcos pesqueros vietnamitas en
el mar de la china meridional pero
seamos honestos Esto no es nada nuevo
para Vietnam Al fin y al cabo ambos
países ya estuvieron en guerra en 1979
justo después de que terminara la famosa
guerra civil en la que intervino Estados
Unidos pero un momento no se supone que
ambos son países con regímenes
comunistas acaso es que no les unía el
socialismo internacional
Pues sí ambos eran y supuestamente
siguen siendo regímenes comunistas
férreos pero queridos amigos amigas
cuando se trata de luchas de poder la
ideología pasa un segundo plano El caso
es que no puede extrañarnos que Vietnam
esté intentando fortalecerse todo lo
posible para evitar otra posible
invasión China y desde luego qué queréis
que os diga su historia nos dice que es
el movimiento más inteligente que puede
hacer y claro Esto es algo que como
veremos a Estados Unidos le interesa Y
mucho pensadlo bien Estados Unidos
quiere frenar el expansionismo chino en
el mar de la China meridional y en
general en todo el lindo Pacífico un
objetivo compartido por Vietnam un país
que podría jugar aquí un papel crucial
con casi 10 millones de habitantes y un
crecimiento económico impresionante en
los últimos años poco a poco Vietnam se
ha perfilado como otro futuro contrapeso
regional a China otro más ya sabéis
junto a Japón Corea del Sur Singapur
filipinas posiblemente la India y otros
tantos países de la zona la posición de
China no es tan fuerte como podríamos
pensar a simple vista
[Música]
ahora bien no podemos olvidar que
Vietnam sigue siendo una dictadura
comunista y hacer alianzas con regímenes
tan autoritarios puede conllevar un
montón de problemas no hay más que ver
la situación de la otan con Turquía Pero
de eso hablaremos en otro vídeo por
ahora la pregunta es de verdad puede
occidente fiarse de Vietnam Hasta qué
punto podría llegar a convertirse en un
socio militar fiable para Estados Unidos
podrían las tensiones entre Vietnam y
China terminar provocando otra guerra
queridos amigos amigas hoy vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
antes antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
y ante eso os hago una pregunta sabes
todo lo que te estás perdiendo por no
usar surfshark lo primero y más
importante la protección de Navegar de
forma completamente segura te protege
descifrando tu actividad en internet de
modo que nadie pueda rastrear ni robar
tus datos bloquea anuncios y malware con
Clean web y protege tus cuentas de
correo electrónico con surfshark alert
avisándote así cuando se filtre tu
información personal pero espera porque
aún hay más
la primera VPN comercial con servidores
en más de 100 países distintos lo que
significa que puedes abrir a golpe de
clic un nuevo mundo de contenidos
restringidos Según tu ubicación además
con una misma cuenta podrás registrar
todos los dispositivos que quieras sin
límite tu teléfono tu tablet las Smart
TV el portátil etcétera etcétera y lo
mejor de todo por ser parte de la
comunidad visualpolitik podrás disfrutar
de un 83% de descuento y 3 meses gratis
usando el código politic terminado en K
pero dicho esto continuamos con nuestro
vídeo de hoy
[Música]
encrucijada del comunismo asiático
cuando nos fijamos en la historia y
vemos Cómo se organizan internamente
tanto china como Vietnam vemos Que a
primera vista Parece ser realidades
básicamente paralelas ambos países
llevaron a cabo revoluciones socialistas
ambos establecieron dictaduras
comunistas que aún perduran y ambos
empezaron a reformar sus economías para
abrirse de paren para el mercado
internacional Claro que Vietnam empezó
su reforma económica en 1986 con el doy
Es decir 8 años después de que se
pusieran en marcha las reformas
económicas de Denzel en la República
popular china el caso queridos amigos es
que ambos países comenzaron a promover
la propiedad privada en el campo y bueno
también en el resto de la economía
potenciaron a sí mismo la inversión
extranjera e intensificaron sus
relaciones comerciales con el resto del
mundo Gracias a este cambio al final
cosecharon un jugoso resultado tal y
como podéis ver sus economías comenzaron
a despegar
china que comenzó sus reformas casi una
década antes se distancia de Vietnam
sobre todo cuando se integró la
Organización Mundial del Comercio a
comienzos del siglo XXI Pero no importa
en general los dos países han seguido
una trayectoria más que notable en
apenas 30 años Vietnam ha multiplicado
el valor real de su producción por 12
Claro que china lo ha hecho casi por 20
Y es que lo cierto Es que hablamos de
dos países con muchas similitudes pero
al mismo tiempo también con muchas
diferencias en el caso de Vietnam además
de llegar casi una década más tarde a la
oleada de reformas económicas hay que
tener en cuenta que cuando esta ola
finalmente llegó al país este acaba de
pasar por dos guerras una guerra civil
en la que participó Estados Unidos y más
tarde una guerra contra la misma china
que salió en defensa del régimen
camboyano de uno de los mayores
genocidas de toda la historia paulfod en
general podemos decir que Vietnam abrazó
las reformas cuando era más pobre y
tenía incluso más problemas de todo tipo
que la República popular china en parte
Esa diferencia es lo que explica la
brecha actual claro que hoy en día las
diferencias va mucho más allá del
terreno económico china entre el poder y
el personalismo de silvin Exacto
mientras que en los últimos años en
China el personalismo llevado al extremo
ha vuelto a ganar fuerza en Vietnam la
cosa aparece completamente diferente y
prueba de ello Son noticias como esta el
presidente de Vietnam engulle medio de
la campaña anticorrupción del partido
comunista Y es que veréis en China desde
1989 el secretario general del partido
comunista ha sido también el presidente
del país en Vietnam en cambio hoy por
hoy esto parece impensable
[Música]
de hecho la dictadura comunista
vietnamitada Descansa en cuatro Pilares
la secretaría general el Primer Ministro
el presidente y el líder de la asamblea
nacional Pues bien desde la muerte de Ho
chi min Ni más ni menos que 1969 Y mira
que ha llovido cada uno de estos cargos
ha recaído en personas diferentes que
funcionan en cierta forma contrapesos
unos de otros y de hecho la asamblea
nacional de Vietnam que a ver
evidentemente no es democrática al menos
sí que tiene algo de actividad real
incluso puede evitar resoluciones y
llegado el caso o proponer mociones de
confianza contra el Primer Ministro y
digamos que hasta ahora esto ha
permitido oxigenar algo más el aparato
oficial Sí en China existía la
alternancia del líder y de las élites
políticas Pero consiguin eso ha
desaparecido y Qué significa todo esto
Pues básicamente que en vietna nadie
puede cambiar el rumbo así por las
buenas como en cambio si puedo hacer sin
pin en China y generalmente estas cosas
también conllevan menos restricciones
para la población por ejemplo mientras
que en China Facebook y YouTube están
totalmente bloqueados en vietna que son
relativamente libre existen ciertas
restricciones pero el acceso
relativamente libre incluso a vídeos que
critican al propio Partido Comunista
pero en cualquier caso aparte del
proyecto político interno donde
encontramos las mayores diferencias
entre ambos países Es sobre todo en su
política en el mar de la china
meridional Aunque Bueno también tienen
una importante similitud ambos países
reclaman los mismos territorios Y eso
implica que las tensiones podrían llegar
a dispararse Y repetirse de nuevo la
historia no olvidéis que ambos países
estuvieron ya en guerra en 1979 y la
pregunta es cómo espera Vietnam evitar
que la tensión se dispare con su vecino
del Norte Pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
desde Rusia con amor
es inevitable cada vez que nos hablan de
vivienda automáticamente pensamos en
aquella guerra de la que se han hecho
docenas de películas y en la que Estados
Unidos se involucró apoyando al sur del
país con decenas y decenas de miles de
soldados para que os hagáis una idea En
1968 la potencia norteamericana llegó a
tener desplegados casi 600.000 soldados
en este país en total Estados Unidos
participó en esta guerra durante 12
larguísimos años pero seguro que lo que
muchos no sabíais es que justo después
de que acabara esta contienda sin
invadió Vietnam 1979 y Aparentemente hoy
las cosas no serían muy diferentes la
exposición de Vietnam a China sigue
siendo Sencillamente enorme
[Música]
fijaos si no en este mapa si prestáis
atención a este mapa os daréis cuenta de
que Vietnam está totalmente a merced del
gigante asiático ya sea por su frontera
en el norte que fue por donde los chinos
les invadieron en el 79 como por la
costa donde además de estar
prácticamente rodeados se enfrentan a la
mayor armada por número de barcos de del
planeta y luego no olvidemos que por el
sur está Camboya que es aliada de China
y luego laos que es un país que podría
cambiar de mando a conveniencia del
mejor postor y claro entonces ante tal
panorama La pregunta es realmente puede
Vietnam tener un discurso claramente
independiente Pues sabéis que
básicamente Este es el motivo que
explica Por qué los últimos años Vietnam
ha intentado acercarse cada vez más y
más a países como Japón o la India tanto
militar como comercialmente pero claro
seamos honestos la amistad entre estos
países es hoy por hoy al menos más bien
superficial Sí de verdad queremos
encontrar al que siempre ha sido el
mejor amigo de Vietnam nos tenemos que
ir al país que ha copado todas las
portadas de la prensa internacional
Durante este último año Exacto estamos
hablando de Rusia
[Música]
ya desde la época de xochimin la
influencia de Moscú en el país ha sido
infinitamente mayor que la de Pekín en
cierto modo esto tiene mucho que ver con
que las raíces del pensamiento comunista
de Vietnam procedan directamente del
marxismo leninismo soviético por lo
tanto no es de extrañar que sus lazos
con la unión soviética fuesen tan
estrechos lo que explica en buena medida
porque Estados Unidos se tomó tan en
serio esta guerra un conflicto en el que
las tropas nor vietnamitas contaron con
el apoyo y la asistencia de la unión
soviética que es exactamente lo que
volvió a suceder cuando en 1979 china
invadió el país como represalia por el
hecho de que Vietnam hubiera atacado y
derrocado al sangriento régimen de los
gemelos rojos en Camboya
ya fuera durante la guerra contra
Estados Unidos o contra la invasión
China la unión soviética el socio más
fiel de la Vietnam comunista ayudó al
país enviando un montón de armas Como
por ejemplo misiles antiaéreos
ametralladoras ligeras o el famosísimo
fusil de asalto ak-47 El caso es que si
sus relaciones ya eran de por sí
estrechas a partir de ese momento la
amistad fue mucho muchísimo más sólida
de hecho hoy en día Rusia sigue siendo
el mayor socio en términos de armas del
ejército vietnamita y de hecho Rusia
tiene incluso acceso preferente a una de
las bases vietnamitas más importantes la
de la Bahía de Cam Run pero ojo porque
ahí No termina todo
no confió la unión soviética y en la
Rusia actual sólo para conseguir armas
la cooperación económica también ha sido
clave durante buena parte de este tiempo
creéis un ejemplo relativamente reciente
Pues fijaos en los últimos años Vietnam
ha intentado extraer petróleo en el mar
de la china meridional lo ha hecho de la
mano de un montón de multinacionales sin
ir más lejos de repsol Sin embargo
hablamos de zonas en disputa y claro el
petróleo iba a salir más rápido y con
menos problemas si se metía alguna
empresa Estatal rusa de por medio que
digamos lograra intimidar un poquito Tan
solo un poquito a China sobre todo por
el miedo a perjudicar sus relaciones con
Moscú O mejor dicho el empeño de simping
de mantener esa relación y como no la
primera en avanzarse sobre esta
oportunidad fue rosneft Aunque luego
está Le vendiera toda su participación a
otra empresa energética del Estado ruso
en cualquier caso os hago una pregunta
cómo creéis que Vietnam le devuelve
estos favores a Rusia pues queridos
amigos amigas con noticias como esta
vietnami Tailandia se ABS tienen la
votación de la ONU para condenar la
anexión rusa de Ucrania Exacto Vietnam
es uno de los pocos países de todo el
mundo que evitan condenar la invasión
rusa de Ucrania
y en cierto modo tiene algo de sentido
si no llega a ser por el apoyo constante
de la unión soviética antes y del actual
Rusia después posiblemente vivienda no
sería lo que es hoy en día pero a ver el
problema es que si llegado el caso china
Quisiera dar un golpe de mano y castigar
O cambiar al gobierno vietnamita o
incluso invadir este país para
convertirlo en una especie de estado
satélite los rusos no serían una gran
ayuda más bien no serían una ayuda hoy
por hoy dadas las nuevas capacidades del
ejército chino y las debilidades
manifiestas de Rusia sería muy difícil
por no decir imposible que Moscú pudiera
serles de alguna utilidad y no lo dudéis
en hanoi tienen esto claro meridiano Al
fin y al cabo tienen a su lado a una de
las mayores potencias del mundo una
potencia cada vez más expansionista y
con la que no se llevan particularmente
bien y en cualquier caso no quieren ser
un país satélite
[Aplausos]
para evitar un posible choque en los
últimos años en hanoi han intentado
mejorar sus relaciones con Pekín Y es
que no se trata solo de una cuestión
territorial o militar para situarnos
casi el 40% de todas las importaciones
vietnamitas provienen de China lo que
incluye circuitos integrados teléfonos
semiconductores En definitiva
Prácticamente todo lo que el país
necesita para desarrollarse
tecnológicamente
esto explica por ejemplo Por qué ambos
países han realizado lo que llevamos de
siglo decenas de ejercicios de
cooperación militar Y sobre todo explica
la política exterior basada en la
filosofía de los tres no es esto es no
permitir bases militares extranjeras en
Vietnam no formar parte de alianzas
militares y no apoyar a un país en su
lucha contra otro todo para no enfadar
la china Pero y si os dijera que esta
reducción podría haber sido un error
pese a todo Las tensiones en el mar de
la china meridional llevan
incrementándose durante la última década
y la situación amigos amigas en la zona
ya no es para tomársela a la ligera
atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
dejando el pasado atrás
bien ya os hemos contado antes como
Vietnam se marcó una serie de reformas
económicas por mercado a partir del año
86 es algo de lo que ya os hemos hablado
en un pasado vídeo aquí en visualpolitik
con todo detalle pero para los que no lo
hayáis visto o simplemente pues no os
acordáis por aquí un pequeño
recordatorio al principio esta reforma
se limitaron al sector agrícola para
después saltar al resto de áreas
productivas entre las que destacó la
búsqueda toda costa de la
industrialización del país lo cual para
tener éxito exigía recibir y cortejar a
los inversores del resto del mundo y
amigos se lo tomaron muy pero que muy en
serio hoy en día no es extraño que
veamos como marcas de todo el mundo
producen ya en Vietnam hablamos de
compañías tan conocidas como Samsung hym
Adidas Nike offcom de hecho el mayor
cliente de Vietnam por mucha diferencia
es Estados Unidos lo que no resulta nada
sorprendente las relaciones con la
superpotencia norteamericana han
mejorado mucho en los últimos años
atrás quedaron los tiempos de la guerra
y la desconfianza en 1995 los dos países
restablecieron formalmente sus
relaciones diplomáticas en el año 2000
firmaron un acuerdo comercial bilateral
en 2007 Vietnam se unió la Organización
Mundial del Comercio con el apoyo
explícito de Washington y en 2016
Estados Unidos levantó por completo el
embargo de armas que pesaba sobre este
país lo que permitió una mayor
cooperación entre más de seguridad y
defensa incluso todos pudimos ver
imágenes como estas
desde entonces los dos países han
desarrollado numerosos ejercicios
militares conjuntos y habitualmente
colaboran en la seguridad marítima y la
libertad de navegación en la región de
lindo Pacífico pero ahora bien si hemos
dicho antes que Vietnam ha intentado
llevarse lo mejor posible con china que
explica que de repente quiera crear un
vínculo con su histórico archienemigo Y
hoy por hoy también gran adversario de
la República Popular de China
Pues Más allá de cuestiones económicas
Lo cierto es que en Halloween no se fían
un pelo de Pekín de hecho en 2014 la
tensión entre ambos países llegó un
nivel extremo cuando china lleva una
plataforma petrolera semi sumergible
para explorar y explotar petróleo en
territorio marítimo vietnamita y no solo
eso la construcción de Islas
artificiales en torno a los
archipiélagos es Patrick percell que la
propia Vietnam reclama como propias han
hecho que la tensión no deje de crecer
en la región especialmente por el
Hardware militar que china está
instalando en todas estas Islas por eso
en hanoi parecen entender ahora que ni
Moscú ni Pekín son sus mejores garantías
sino que estas pueden proceder de
Estados Unidos y su órbita de países
aliados en la zona por supuesto en
Washington han visto esta jugada como
todo un golpe de Fortuna algo así como
otro potencial socio sumar a su ya larga
lista de países enfadados o recelosos de
China y en cierto modo eso es lo que
explica noticias como estas 29 de marzo
de 2018 Estados Unidos transfiera
20 de noviembre de 2019 Estados Unidos
le regala un barco a Vietnam para
reforzar las patrullas en el disputado
mar de China meridional 17 de diciembre
de 2022 análisis Vietnam cambia de
marcha en el comercio de armas y afloja
lazos con Rusia ahora en vez de estar
comprando armas rusas son las armas
estadounidenses surcoreanas e israelíes
las que están inundando Vietnam ahora
bien significa esto que Vietnam va a
cambiar su filosofía de los tres no es y
se va a echar por completo a los brazos
del Tío Sam pues definitivamente no
tienda es un extraño caso de país que
hoy Parece que llevarse bien con Pekín
Moscú y Washington al mismo tiempo y no
nos engañemos viéndome sigue siendo una
dictadura comunista los valores
políticos y democráticos occidentales no
forman parte del partido comunista y
Esto hace que la confianza que Estados
Unidos pueda tener en Vietnam pues no
sea demasiado alta pensado bien parece
casi imposible hoy por hoy imaginarnos a
un Vietnam interviniendo junto a Estados
Unidos para evitar que china se haga con
el control de Taiwán nos parece sea como
si ahora la pregunta es para todos
vosotros de ser el gobierno de Vietnam
por quien toma diez partido por Moscú
por Pekín o por Washington déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y hablamos
debate si este vídeo se resulta
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros a visualpolitik si es que
aún no lo habéis hecho Ah importante y
recordad que con el código pollity que
acabado en K podréis disfrutar de un 83%
de descuento y 3 meses gratis de
subshark el link como siempre os lo
dejamos en la descripción y en los
comentarios Muchas gracias una vez más
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]